mathieu du club massiac neuf mois ci a
dit claude mathieu du ce nom casimir est
ce que c'est un julie sétois bonjour je
cherche
monsieur duchesneau ben tu vois tu je me
doutais et ce n'est pas une raison pour
casser les oreilles de tout le monde
comme il faut je le vois très vite c'est
important et bien jusque chez lui ou
jusqu'au port mais des places toit au
lieu de crier
bon je comprends il ne faut jamais que
je parle fort alors pour ce qu'azimut
vraiment une victime
oui exactement tiens tu veux abobo oh
oui je veux bien oui je voudrais ankara
mer et caramel à temps voilà
certainement pas comme ça un de ceux que
tu caches les blés beau que tu mets dans
mes phares c'est non merci julie à tout
à l'heure
est monsieur du snob ça vraiment
monsieur des snobs
oui ce sont de très belles photos n'est
ce pas et regardez cet éléphant ne dit
pas impressionné c'est vrai il a une
tronche superbe
n'est ce pas vous disiez que vous
connaissez l'artiste qui a fait ces
photos
non c'est un ami à vous moi je n'ai pas
encore rencontré mais c'est le camarade
du cousin du beau frère d'un de mes amis
alors je vais très certainement leur
rencontre est très bon je n'en doute pas
monsieur des slaves
vous voilà donc avec un personnage de
qualité de plus dans votre entourage
n'est ce pas dire est que j'attire les
gens de qualité comme comme un aimant
non ce qui me procure surtout une très
grande joie voyez vous c'est que tous
mes amis peuvent en profiter
messieurs listenable ma très chère amie
que de soin de vous voir comment marche
vos affaires c'est calme mais je me
pardonnez moi de vous couper mais je
pense tout à coup que françois et vous
ne vous êtes pas saluer seriez-vous
passion a pas dit
mais simplement monsieur du snob nous
nous sommes déjà rencontré quatre fois
aujourd'hui on ne peut pas passer son
temps à se dire bonjour à pardonnez moi
je voulais donc vous dire que casimir
vous cherche partout à que veut-il ce
bon que émir mais je ne sais pas mais ça
a l'air très urgent a beau de quel côté
faut-il que j'aille pour le rencontrer
le site isner de silicium ne bougeait
pas à vous attendez le ici il repassera
obligatoirement par le jardin parce que
vous risqueriez de vous couvrir pendant
des heures l'un derrière l'autre
venez vous avez raison je vais
l'attendre avec vous je les regarde
regarde les belles photos que monsieur
du snob vient d'acheter
ils sont très regardants très aimable on
pourrait les montrer à casimir aux si
vous le permettez j'aimerais lui faire
une petite farce si elle n'est pas
méchante mais pas du tout je voudrais
simplement lui faire croire que c'est
moins qu'un touriste il faut tout lors
de mes voyages en france d'un biseau
voyons ma très chère amie vous savez
très bien que qu'un véritable chasseur
d'imagés photographiques des animaux en
liberté
ah oui mais alors il faudra enlever
certaines photos mais aussi du snob
julie a parfaitement raison même casimir
découvrira qu'il s'agit d'une farce si
vous lui montrez ddm ou des éléphants en
lui disant que vous les avez
photographié en suisse opprimerait tout
à fait raison voulez-vous faire le choix
vous même ou préférez-vous que j'appelle
les enfants évidemment je lui ai besoin
de l'aide de personne non ça prend
toujours refusé les offres ses formes
d'accords maîtrise le jeu des appels
bien moi je vous quitte
j'ai des rangements affaires au revoir
julie les enfants on sent venir avec
nous nous allons faire un jeu merci
monsieur les snobs
venez tous voilà de quoi il s'agit
monsieur du snob a besoin que vous
l'aidiez garder il a une magnifique
collection de photos dalino mais il ne
sait pas ce qu'ils vivent en liberté en
france voulait bien l'aider
oui vous avez bien compris il ne s'agit
pas des animaux des eaux mais uniquement
des animaux que l'on peut trouver en
liberté en france lorsqu'on se promène
dans la campagne
commençons par celui ci comment
s'appelle cet animal c'est un sanglier
on en trouve en france tient
parfaitement raison on trouve les
sangliers dans les forêts françaises
tenez monsieur laisse noble à quel est
cet oiseau curieux c'est pas héros
exactement c'est un martin pêcheur on en
trouve en france
ah oui on le retrouve dans les lacs
quelle est la particularité cet oiseau
martin-pêcheur châssis chasse et il
mange quoi ils mangent du poisson très
direct
quelle est cette 1e dalle ce sont des
singes en trouve tout en france
non on ne trouve pas de sage en france
on en trouve un peu partout en afrique
en asie en amérique et même en europe
qui n'a pas beaucoup en europe on en
trouve sur le rocher de gibraltar
alors tenez monsieur du snob ou quel est
ce qu un animal starring féroce il y en
a en france
non ou à tout flou
[Musique]
très bien très bonnes réponses
en france non en afrique très bien si tu
ce non attendez ça ou c'est une girafe
évidemment il y en a qui en france nous
en afrique également alors c'est facile
charge un boeuf une vache est à vous il
y en a en france
évidemment il y en a dans la campagne
française
voilà non c'est pas ça moi c'est un
mouflon irait-il en france si on ne
retrouve on en trouve notamment dans les
alpes c'est un animal qui vit dans la
montagne de neige
c'est un élan on en trouve en france où
entre temps on en trouve au canada du
réseau et on en trouve également dans
les pays nordiques suède norvège
finlande
celui ci fixe et inserts on en trouve en
france si on en trouve dans les forêts
françaises et enfin celui ci est
magnifique un éléphant
il y en a en france il y en a pas ou au
trot tôt
celui ci c'est un éléphant d'afrique
voilà monsieur j'entends quasi mafieux
du ceba ne dit rien les enfants monsieur
du snob va faire une farce et magazines
vous voilà j'ai un message pour vous tu
me le dira tout cas leur qu'elle ait mis
en jeu
je reviens de france à l'instant même et
je veux être montré les photos
extraordinaires que je viens de faire
regarde des photos faites par jour ils
s'en remettront pas dans le temps dans
les photos non monsieur du snob vous
avez le bon paquet à bout ce n'est pas
la peine de parler à voix basse je sais
que c'est une blague mais tu es nerveux
à la fin pourquoi dis-tu ça mais je vous
cherche depuis une heure
monsieur petit oiseau le photographe
m'envoie pour vous dire que votre
appareil photo qui était cassé et chez
lui depuis un mois est enfin réparée
[Musique]